[Music]
what you're about to see may disturb you
once everyone is gone coast is clear
they are going to pull ballots
out from underneath a table there's the
table going in that we're talking about
where the ballots were
obscured so now they're going to start
pulling these ballots out from under
this table
you just pulled one out
[Music]
i saw four suitcases come out from
underneath the table
took it awhile to figure out that's the
same person that you see at night
with the blue apron on who's yelling for
everyone to leave
and who stays behind to help tabulate
balance
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
is bringing back the school of rock
references because yeah we didn't do a
show on thursday because we've been
chasing down some leads
that's what we call it leads chase them
and uh we have some exclusives here
today a little bit we'll have some more
exclusives here before the end of
christmas
um there is so much to get to we will be
talking about
dominion we'll be talking about what
happened in georgia
and uh the bombshell listen this should
change the course of everything people
out there who are watching right now
comment comment comment that's how you
help the algorithm below and i want to
ask you before we go through anything
else
how are you going to fight back how are
you going to fight back
everyone right now what do we do it's
all talk listen i'm not saying that you
should go out and fight in the streets
because that's silly there's
that's equivalent to a thug versus a lex
luthor we live in an age where
information is more important but what
are you
doing because we all know that something
is happening right now that is not right
despite the explanations and you know
what junk black has a mighty set of
pipes because
yeah you're out of breath you need like
you need a second to be able to catch
that
audio wade is here my half asian lawyer
can't be here due to liability reasons
quarter black garrett he's accepted
amongst no communities i
feel bad for him but not so much and uh
token over there gerald a how are you i
am well how are you sir
yeah i didn't know the answer to that
question
um so before we move on to uh
some of the uh what what happened last
week right we posted on crowder bits but
i realized we'd never presented on the
show
the pipe that had burst and how it
didn't burst and then maybe people were
sent home people were not sent home they
stopped counting they didn't stop
counting and
as you see right now on cnn with the
lady in front of the giant concrete
penis nobody cares
why is it a penis i know i'm not
original with that but no you know
exactly why
that was because we were telling the
royalty come on right here
is that where you can is that what a
penis is supposed to look like because
wow that's uh it's well it's supposed
like from
seven oh
what's the scale here i just all right
but first before we get to all of that
matthew mcconaughey is trending this
morning because uh
he dared to criticize and i watched this
whole interview with russell brand
who's trying to rebrand himself now as a
moderate even though he's done
everything
oh wow sorry i'm out stop it
this isn't the view
all right matthew mcconaughey dared to
criticize the far left in their
intolerance hypocrisy and so this is
what has people uh
livid uh let's show the clip for some
more context on the other side
on the on the the the far left that
would go well
who do there is a lot on that ill
liberal left that absolutely condescend
patronizer arrogant towards
that other fifty percent many people
were in
do you know you probably i'm sure you
saw in our industry when trump
was voted in four years ago they were in
denial that it was actually that was
real
this and some of what we're in absolute
denial
i don't understand
i remember him back then now he's saying
yeah we need to find common ground in
really the totality
of the difference of our systems of
inequality but back in the day you were
saying on fox news it's like they're sim
they're constantly chopping loaves of
hate handing it out to sheep
oh oh no matthew mcconaughey is talking
about you yeah my problem with friend
singers is not people who are moderate
my problem
with fence sitters right now is people
who try and present themselves as
centrists
when they weren't that way before and
that's russell brent that's not honest
say i was full of crap i was a communist
before and i was aggressive about it
and i was arrogant i was an elitist
toward conservatives and now
i realize that that shtick doesn't work
and so i'm trying to re-brand
myself yeah exactly well the matthew
mcconaughey thing what he said is like
the most boring opinion in the world
yeah and that anybody is upset with that
makes you go okay well i guess that is
he's right right and then his very next
quote was
just like you have uh people in this
election now who seem to be
not you know biden's our guy and they
seem to be uh not accepting that he's
not a very bright guy so don't think
he's your savior
just a country boy yeah it's not hard to
play the bongos
well and that's not criticizing i'm just
saying it particularly frustrates me
because every celebrity that was spewing
vile and hatred not just like having a
contrary opinion to what trump was doing
but like
like alyssa milano was the same way now
it's time to heal and fight
wait what that's like hitler going to
the jews postwar and being like okay so
we should come together
and be friends no sorry
my bad yeah
but you were you were reaching into it
fish hooking it
tearing it open like tito ortiz before
they had to instate that rule
in the early years people realize this
the early ufc had no you could hit in
the nuts you could grab the hair
and then they added rules they added
weight class
weight classes but then they had to add
one more rule because t ortiz would
punch people cut them open and keep
ripping it so they call it the tito
ortiz rule that's just
me that's like ms and then tito ortiz is
like why aren't you giving me a big old
hug
let's unite i know i used to fish hooku
and you can't close your mouth anymore
but
all right uh follow me on instagram
because that's where you get some stuff
there that uh you don't get here
lifestyle stuff you get a little bit a
little bit more of the joe lewis
uh on there right now right here he's
pretty much just like a starfish in a
tank he's a nerd
uh but he's exciting on instagram and of
course dude he's very interested in mug
club
live mug club um crowder election stream
is still the
get 30 dollars off still going because
some people are saying hey joe biden's a
president-elect that's what you should
call them and you know what
i'm probably not gonna no um
and we'll take your live chat after this
uh but comment below that's what can
make sure that people on youtube can't
throw this comment but first it's time
to get
to this story this bombshell that
dropped i think thursday
and the media never covered it and when
this happened we were in the office
watching it saying
if the media doesn't cover this this
they're dead
and they they have no there should be
absolutely a repeal of 230.
oh they need no quarter at this point
and that's not a call to violence i'm
talking about informationally they
cannot be considered legitimate they
can't be considered authoritative
and if youtube has a problem with this
facebook or twitter
i have a half asian kraken not the
sydney power crack and a lot of krakens
uh who would love to speak with you so
let's start this show off with
hopefully the stinger will let me catch
my breath because i am i am angry but in
but righteous anger like that guy over
there talked about
um time to fact check the fact checkers
fact check fact checkers
fact checkers
okay news the news at the end that does
it for me so let me set this up before i
toss to the clip
um for people who hadn't watched this uh
this is what happened
what was dropped at the georgia hearing
there were a lot of claims made at the
georgia hearing about people who were
underage voting people from out of state
there are more than enough of those
verifiable claims to uh not only
overturn the state of georgia but they
far exceed the margin of victory we'll
get into dominion in a second
these are different facets but i want to
try and distill this
for you this one is very important to me
because
it is a clear-cut example of
all of these sort of i guess you would
say cogs in the wheel
uh the media local election officials
state election election officials
national election officials
and big tech disseminating information
that is completely false
then when verifiable evidence produces
this shows that yes that it is
verifiably false i said oh
no that was a game of telephone uh we
misspoke
and everyone in the media misspoke right
and everyone at big tech misspoke
and senator hirono in hawaii misspoke
and uh just you know what it was one big
misunderstanding there is no
accountability so this is some we
remember this because we were election
night let me set this up for you
election night we were covering for what
was it 14 hours in like forever
yeah including both streams and we
talked about how georgia machines went
down
stopped working like oh okay and then i
remember covering live a pipe burst so
they had to stop
right counting in georgia yeah go back i
don't want to we weren't
this is our own show we didn't have time
to go through 14 hours of footage but it
did happen on election night
yeah and i need to tell you this i'm
going to hold myself accountable i
provided you
with misinformation accidentally why
because abc nbc cbs fox news everyone
said a pipe had burst and so they were
going to resume counting later
we didn't know at that moment in time
that when they said we were going to
resume counting later
they meant uh right now so i presented
you with misinformation because i
believe that a pipe had burst on me i'm
holding myself accountable there you go
it doesn't look
like that happened and they did not stop
counting
hmm but that's what all of us
were fed the night of the election
everyone
and i will prove to you uh in graphic
detail so i apologize some of these
videos are a little bit long but i think
you need the context
and this should be really the only uh
segment that you
need on this topic i always recommend
that you go to livecredit.com check the
sources right check auxiliary sources
make sure that i'm right you're right
link in the description but this is
something you can share with people who
don't understand it so
we were told they stopped counting a
pipe burst people were uh
that's what we were told yeah right
people were supposed to go home no no
more counting was going to then they
said well hold on a second no no one was
sent home
that was their defense after that yeah
no one was sent home
actually that's a lie and that only came
up because of sworn affidavits from
people saying hold on a second we were
sent home they continued counting
now we have video from four different
angles
showing that people were sent home and
they continued counting
this is a two minute video but it's
important to watch this was shown at the
georgia hearing that you never saw
according to the witnesses the
republican observers there is a lady
who has blonde braids who comes out to
announce we're going to stop counting
everyone go home and in fact we see that
what happens is everyone clears out so
what you're going to see
look at the ladies in yellow you'll see
that they will begin just sitting still
doing nothing ostensibly
they will wait until the witnesses over
there in that roped off area the press
and the observers
leave the room then you'll see them move
into action
and begin scanning ballads once everyone
is gone
coast is clear they are going to pull
ballots out from underneath a table
there you go so now they're going to
start pulling these ballots out from us
notice that lady in the purple because
we'll go back to her in a little bit
this table the black one was placed
there
by the lady with the blonde braids
okay so 8 21 you'll notice
the table's not there at all here it
comes there's the table going in that
we're talking about where the ballots
were
obscured that lady who's moving it is
the lady with the blonde braids
she's dressed differently in the morning
so it took us a while to figure out
that's the same person that you see at
night
with a blue apron on who's yelling for
everyone to leave
and who stays behind to help tabulate
ballots after they've all left
yeah i saw four suitcases come out from
underneath the table
[Music]
so he just pulled one out so what are
these ballots doing there
separate from all the other ballots and
why are they only counting them whenever
the place is cleared out with no
witnesses
these machines can process about three
thousand ballots an hour
that's pivotal because we'll show some
numbers there
we believe that could easily be and
probably is certainly
beyond the margin of victory in this
race because if it's only three scanners
working for two hours
right that's 18 000 ballots that went
through and so if we were to sit here
for the next two hours what we would see
is this operation just goes
on and on and on but most people can't
be bothered to sit there for two hours
i can't michael
it's on you well you should for crying
out
loud this is one of the now of course
the argument is like well no actually no
one was sent home we'll get to that in a
second
first off did you really did you have to
those people all
rushed out of there faster when they
pull the pterodactyl's ass on the
flintstone and fred
slides down the brontosaurus and they
played closing time
don't fat check that that's not true but
i'm just exaggerating to make a point
but well it's like you stopping the show
right now and being like okay we're done
streaming
and i'm like okay should i leave yeah i
don't know it's up to you we've done
that
yeah yeah then i leave and you're like
oh gerald left i can't believe you
little buddy
no no except they don't say you can't
believe left i'm like good gerald's
oh gone okay where's your christmas
spirit this was presented
and what was interesting was for several
days snopes factcheck.org
washington post no pinocchios no
no politifact meter no mostly true
mostly false
nothing it was only a fact check from
some broad who's a photographer in
seattle ah yeah
qualified and then they came up with the
explanation first off they said well
those aren't suitcases
okay they look like suitcases and they
try to say well actually the bins were
empty
no they weren't empty then they said
well actually they filled the bins with
the press there and it's
okay none of this matters let me explain
to you why but first their primary
defense is
no burst pipe right there no pipe
actually burst and the pole watchers
weren't sent home this is what they're
saying now
when they claim they've debunked this
video here
the water pipe leak and the events on
the surveillance video did not happen
on the same night those two events
occurred 17 hours apart
how do we know we were there early this
morning we told there is
a target the workers leaving were those
who
opened the ballot envelopes and once
they were done processing that batch
they went home at about 10 o'clock there
was one person
working the polls who told everyone in
the room
to leave no announcement was ever made
to to weave was anyone actually told to
leave
or just that they were done they were
made to leave
so it was done in contravention to the
statute both 11 alive journalists on
site that night independently confirmed
to me
that they were not told to leave but
they were told
counting was done for the night okay
well first off
that's important because then the guy
said no no accounting we clearly saw the
counting didn't stop yes
how was that better pick a [ __ ] lane
[Laughter]
so yeah so the claim was that there were
envelope people and then there were
counters
right there so yeah so the cutters they
sent the cutters home right
but who would not have understood at all
that they were simply cutters these are
people who you know you have people in
sworn affidavits saying no actually we
were told to leave and at that point all
the press left which just tells me
the press is [ __ ] yeah right this is
also why they what they don't want to
admit like no we all left
and by the way the people you say right
there this is the difference this is
what's important
it's like it's like fighting somebody
else when you have a hundred pound vest
on
yeah are they under under oath under
penalty of perjury the people who told
you that
because the people who went along with
your original story
are and they said they were told to go
home
which is what you told us so we have
what you talk this is what they're
saying now
but it doesn't matter because that's not
what you told us and i don't i don't
just mean a couple of people online with
internet conspiracy theories what i mean
is the night we covered the election
every single major news media including
the place that airs sesame street pbs
repeatedly quoted they quoted the
election officials and director so i
would like to get that guy under oath
here's my thing right now we'll show
this
you nee we need to have some subpoenas
and subpoenas
enunciation is key you got it
we need to have subpoenas members of the
press and the election
officials okay members of the press did
you willingly lie
or were you given false information in
which case the election
officials should be held under oath
under penalty of perjury because
both groups can't have made a mistake
right both groups can't have made a
repeated mistake and now you just go oh
hold on a second we made a mistake
someone needs to be held accountable
because on election night
this is the exact story you saw
everywhere
there is now a hitch in the tabulation
of votes
i'm standing in fulton county fulton
county includes a chunk of atlanta
downtown atlanta is state farm arena
where the atlanta hawks play
they are tabulating the absentee ballots
of fulton county
georgia's most populous county a water
pipe has broken inside the arena
they had counted 86 000 absentee ballots
we don't know how many more
they have yet to tabulate but all the
tabulation of those ballots has now
stopped
also there was a water pipe that burst
in the state farm arena where they're
tabulating votes at least 50 000 votes
we believe right there
uh were paused because
according to officials a three to four
hour delay they decided to stop counting
last night
we have about 24 and then fulton has
also been slow going they were delayed
because of a
a pipe that burst earlier and within
half an hour of him arriving at five
this morning
a pipe had burst at the state farm arena
where they were scanning and tabulating
the last batch of mail-in
and absentee votes from georgia
apparently at the state farm arena
they were delayed four hours because of
a water pipe burst in that room
um and they don't expect as you say bill
that fulton county will come in for
quite some time fulton county
most populous county it is atlanta
they just stopped counting at 10 30 p.m
they stopped counting their absentee
ballots they said they'd pick it up in
the morning
both fired and subpoenaed because they
didn't stop counting
what they did hold on a second give me a
fact check
yeah there we go counting
every single person subpoena or fired
take
your pick and then we go to the election
official mr barron hold on a second
if this was a game of telephone let's
take this into account their argument as
there was a game of telephone yeah
there's some people some people should
go home some people should no no
everyone left
including the press then they signed
sworn affidavits saying we were told to
leave and now you're saying no they
weren't and the counting didn't stop
it doesn't matter what the claim is now
to debunk it
right because you're debunking
yourselves and don't blame conservatives
for you know what it shame on us
we trusted you yes they said yeah they
said this happened
we said okay well here's a video of that
not happening why would they tell
us about that you believed us that's
your fault come here
all right well hold up yeah how do you
explain them continuing counting after
they said they had stopped counting well
we haven't been told what to say about
that yet
yeah yeah we haven't got the doubt
marching orders
no as of this moment i don't understand
and by the way if you're the election
official because this is their argument
too
they say i think this was a media they
said it was a game of telephone where he
said people had left
but then people actually weren't told to
leave and so they were told to come back
if i'm seeing every single major news
outlet by the way including this one who
beat all those outlets that you saw that
night
thank you by the way for tuning in to
join up you know what i do i go oh
i might actually be held accountable for
this uh let me go no no you guys are
getting the story wrong you guys are
getting the story wrong we didn't tell
anyone to leave they didn't only report
at the night of the election they
reported the next morning
after the election it was a continued
story until it was
repeatedly debunked first no pipe burst
well it was a toilet seal
oh a toilet seal why would that affect
the outcome
of voting how big of a pansy are you
listen we're government workers and or
volunteers
we don't have the constitution to do
this you ever had a paper cut
yeah and if this is true then they only
corrected the record
a month later right after the video came
out and so why didn't they do this ahead
of time right
they realized what they said do you know
what when this happened by the way when
so let's follow his timeline pipe burst
people were sent home yeah okay now they
say no but
at that time pipe burst people were sent
home they said counting stopped counting
didn't stop
and it happened at the time there was a
massive voting spike for biden
oh wow who knew that
that almost seems like it was planned
now granted could be totally unrelated
also this is something i have a problem
with we're saying they can count 3000
votes per hour
but you have many precincts that have
far exceeded what the machines could
actually process
so who's to say three thousand thirty
thousand
a hundred thousand screw you you're
crazy for asking questions
right well look the law just clearly
states it doesn't matter if it was a
suitcase or an election
box transport or whatever it was it
doesn't matter they're not supposed to
be counting votes in that situation
they shouldn't all go inert right they
shouldn't all just sit there and freeze
and then 45 seconds five minutes
whatever it was later go oh let's start
counting
here yeah exactly
exactly and they walked out and they
started playing semi-sonic again i know
right to take me home well i am so
tired of the lies right now and that
anyone is actually buying it
and the only reason is because the media
is blocking
yeah everything no accountability you
guys let us know when we're wrong
all the time all the time right and if
your goal is to have
an open free and fair election and by
the way at 10 30 at night we
knew this was going to be contested we
were seeing some staggering margins for
trump
right going into some of these counts
that they were doing for absentee
ballots
why wouldn't you say hey we accidentally
sent everyone home
or we didn't send anybody home but they
all left i have no idea maybe like their
favorite restaurants closing we'll call
them all back we'll wait it doesn't
matter you can't call their ass stars
yeah because you can't count without
them right
call them back that's right now they're
saying no they didn't start counting
they were just tabulating things that
other people had verified but the people
who were under sworn affidavits are
saying no
no that's not true so the media goes
with people who are not under penalty of
perjury
who have no accountability because the
media hates accountability
they i was born in the shadows
molded by it but they stayed there
this is the issue with the media so they
they bring in people
who have no skin in the game none yeah
there's no
there's no affidavit it's just like uh
what what happened well people weren't
sent home good enough for me
back to you and they go aw second it
looks like people were sent home what do
you say well those were just the cutters
oh they were just the cutters good
enough for me back to you
all right and uh they st they stopped
counting though right so that's yeah so
people weren't there they stopped
counting
back to you bob oh they didn't stop
counting oh okay so then well you were
just tabulating they were just
tabulating
back to you bob no yeah that's not how
it works
well and i guarantee you the next one
we're going to hear is it wasn't enough
votes to overturn the election right
right
you shouldn't worry about that hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot here on youtube and notifications
let you know when we're live weekday
mornings 10 a.m eastern and comment
comment comment below if you have been
following this
just comment your favorite color for all
i care but apparently that's what
youtube values in the algorithms
now that's what matters is the broken
chain of custody yes also really
you cannot count there are laws in place
that say you can't be counting
uh if there are no if there's no
accountability
right listen we've talked about this
when you when you have two fighters the
fighter's corner his coach goes and
watch them tape the other guy to make
sure there are no nails broken glass you
know
that's what they used to do the italians
were rough they dirty
they dirty whoa roll the pennies maybe
back in the day the italians the irish
they were you know
there was some foul play in early
queensbury boxing
don't worry relax came in they cleaned
it up wow
hey and one jew max bear the point is
there's blame to go around that's true
so talking about the chain of custody
this is something that
not many people are covering that purple
lady with the pur well the purple shirt
not actually purple which by the way if
you're listening to this blonde braids
you probably picture something in your
mind very different watch the video
it is not the wendy's girl peepee long
stockings not the girl from 10
no no nothing like that uh bo derek
yeah she's a conservative and she looks
fine
but that purple lady here she is earlier
again while we're talking about the
chain of custody
and absentee ballots and a lot of people
could miss something
very important here go
don't say anything but you are
broadcasting it
[Laughter]
like anderson cooper going right to
everyone to the nine people in the
airport who watch them
the secret between me and the internet
don't worry i can just delete it it's
not like it's forever
so that's what's going on in fulton
county listen to this
station sir can i have some work
work hurricanes freakin 30 minutes
30 minutes uh-huh that's all you give me
i'm going to give a
i five to work y'all and they talk about
me oh they talk about me
there's some drama there but i think i
understand why
i didn't want to work oh dion thank you
thank you love
when i didn't want to work i took off
for 10 days and i'm back
maybe that's what they talk about maybe
because i've come to work
but now you're here okay good good
that's how it works thank you
oh you're going to give me first you
just give me one god bless you real good
thank you
this is pivotal this is pivotal look at
that
ain't no such thing i'm gonna be here to
seven o'clock
then i'm on leave for four weeks
look at that for people who don't know
what they're watching yeah
i'll go back to it don't mind mrs movie
i'm gonna be counting those i got a lot
to fill out counting those absentee
ballots
first off anyone here who just decides
they don't want to show up for 10 days
uh don't show up for all the days
can you believe that audio wade didn't
show up to work for 10 days and he still
thought he had a job
i know what a [ __ ] right i don't want
to gossip
it's funny when we told him to come in
and change the locks loose lips
sink ships so do the guys who are
actually manning the ships who don't
show up for 10 days
oh i see your point yeah that's the
thing um so she didn't show up for ten
days and she's like i gotta work i gotta
work y'all yeah for people who don't
know what that is let's bring up that
screen
yeah those are absentee ballots with no
return address
now but she's got work to do yeah yeah
the guy is bringing in
fat stacks i believe uh is how they're
commonly referred to
fat stacks of absentee ballots with no
return address which she just said on
camera she is going to
fill out you cannot first off you don't
fill out if there's no return address
objection your honor i'll walk around
shut up you weren't here for 10 days you
don't even know what an objection is you
were you weren't here for the
orientation stop talking about me
objection stop yo gossiping
and there's no one there so we are now
talking about a lady who was
bringing in those bins as we saw earlier
and there are more videos circulating
that we haven't been able to verify yet
who on that night after uh
being m.i.a for 10 days
is filling out absentee ballots with no
return address there
and no watchers who's to say those
aren't the belts when they say people
were doing the cutting and they pulled
them and they put the ballots into the
bins while the press was there
and then later they were just running
them through the tabulator who's to say
they aren't those
again this all coincides when you look
at the incident with a massive voting
spike for biden in a state that is not
really a swing state
yeah it hasn't been for quite a long
time and the only thing that we're
asking look into it
can you just look into it before you say
nope certified nope done we're not going
to do anything look into it who who do
we have to look into it well the state
has two
right and then if the state rules you
luck well i know but the media is not
going to you've got a secretary of state
who i believe
is i believe he was the stand-in for the
eunuch in game of
you have thrones because here's the
thing and i said this when they were
going to do the recount yeah i said
listen
don't expect this recount when it's
there's a reason they're not doing a
hand recount in georgia
because even if you're a republican you
don't want to look like so much of a
dumb ass that a pipe didn't burst people
were sent home right they counted votes
in secret
and you're the one in charge it's not
about republican or democrat at this
point it's about people not wanting to
lose
their jobs and they should
yeah every single one of them and when
donald trump calls the the mayor
sorry the governor and says you
shouldn't certify these results
the media says donald trump is illegally
pressuring him no
all he's saying is enforce your own laws
they weren't followed you have to not
certify this and you have to look into
it let's not bicker about who
broke laws
no let's let's please i would very much
like to bicker about it
it is it is it is one of those things
that is absolutely uh i i mean i don't
know the media just isn't covering it
yeah the media is not covering this
right now let's go to cnn
jeff good they have jeff good and killer
mike
uh talking with jim prosciutto about uh
critical week to pass the aid deal
they want this is what is happening by
the way folks this is what the i talked
about the the
the mental warfare you know you do this
in nazi germany the allies have left
churchill has given up because they
right they want you to
feel alone people are saying why are you
fighting a loser losing battle this
election listen i don't know that it's a
losing battle
and it doesn't matter let me explain to
you something both
someone who only picks fights that they
know they will win is a bully
okay someone who only picks fights that
they know they will lose
is a fool we don't know that we will win
this fight but i do know that we
can win this fight and you all have to
get off your ass and do something
and that means writing your local local
representatives that also means
uh by the way getting out there and
protesting in person in these states
let's show them what actual peaceful
civil unrest looks like because they're
in for a rude
awakening and something else that's
really important by the way a lot of
this is going to go to the supreme court
doesn't necessarily have to because it
can go to the state electors they can
they can certify the election however
they want the supreme court don't think
that the supreme court is beyond
the politics of public opinion okay
right the supreme court they're not
going to be willing to stick their necks
out for something even if they know it's
right
if they know that they will be burned
down for doing so all the supreme court
needs is enough of you to make them
understand
that there are americans out there
there's a large enough portion of
americans
who want what is right to be done
give them the courage the balls
yes to stick their neck out for you
that's why you can't go away quietly
right now there are some victories
there's a victory in seizing dominion
machines we'll get to that in a second
there are victories and moving up some
of the court dates we'll get to that in
a second so
this idea that there isn't any headway
being made you're not paying attention
yeah exactly and do us all a favor have
a high credibility bar for the arguments
that you're going to make make sure
you're going after the stuff that is
absolutely 100
provable don't run with they were
suitcases under the table when they were
not
suitcases don't don't pick little points
out when you go to make these arguments
to friends because those are easily kind
of pushed aside or said no that's not
really true
just go with the fact that vote switch
story it is a samsonite
travel case or nothing i was way off
samsonite
i knew it started with an s though so do
something to say their audio later
i was actually just going to say that
one of one of the strongest arguments
that i've seen is one that trump made
where he talked about how
hillary and obama outperformed biden in
every single state that wasn't a swing
state right
yeah the only places where biden
outperformed anybody
right on planet earth was the places
where everything was the most content
and he underperformed in all the
bellwether counties
right and for some routine with the
urbanites and
yeah black voters where he he
underperformed with them
everywhere else aside from these areas
right so there are statistical
unbelievable there is there is uh there
are plenty of affidavits
and now we have video evidence and this
is what happens they say
where do you present the and by the way
some of the people there at that hearing
who are furious that uh that senator uh
whatever elena whatever it is
where's the this has been debunked you
haven't seen the video yet but uh
what and and by the way it is sorry go
ahead with your point then i'll go back
i was just going to say that on the face
of it it looks like fraud what we were
just talking about the thing
these sort of weird anomalies were this
doesn't track with any pattern
what was the 75 percent of the uh
primary votes
so it's like every every person who's
ever won 75
of the primary votes has won the
presidency right as an incumbent
trump got 94 right so again as we lay
these things out it just starts to look
like
well there's definitely another
explanation right yeah there's
statistics
anybody yeah anybody who thinks that and
they go well listen listen stop doing
this bring your evidence to court
uh you have judges again politically
motivated who will not look at it that's
not evidence
yeah because someone at mediaite says no
we didn't tell people to go home
you told us you did and judges go we're
not going to look at any of the evidence
right
right listen this is enough right here
this is enough
that a judge has to take it and if
testicles
judges in your state won't guess what
it's going to be kicked up to the
supreme court
good luck get down with acb you know me
and you can definitely show three things
that are very important in most trials
which is means
motive and opportunity yeah right they
had the means they had the motive they
had the opportunity and we have video of
them talking now we have hundreds of
affidavits and then we have video
evidence and statistical evidence yeah
th this should be easy this this
shouldn't be a controversial situation
it would be like if with
oj they had the glove they had the
murder weapon
they had his fingerprints they had him
on tape saying
i'm going to kill my wife and love her
and the glove fit
hmm it's the fit part yeah
that's murder where is the evidence i
come to work
i come to work i become diverse okay she
just
she said work one time and someone
thought it would be really funny to
correct and go actually it's verk she's
like okay i sound smart that's a joke
i'm a rocking man what woman
i come to work seven days out of 31
on elite
no republican has ever worked a double
shift by the way ever been in combat
yeah because that's kind of work ever
run a business
where there is no end to your shift ever
i had to clock out and then clock in
again i love the projection
you'd be the one crying in a walk-in
with only a meal break and two other
breaks in between and since i don't
smoke i get to use them for whatever i
want i just you are a monster i
hope that you get primaried next time oh
man
it's so fun one question no threat what
a threat i know i didn't want to issue a
threat because i know it's an empty
threat
nothing's going to happen because new
york is a place where dreams go to die
outside of staten island new york i
don't like sure i love new york
i disagree it's also a place where
citizens go to die it's true that's true
we should
we should we should let you establish uh
residency there and
primary her you know that would be
delivered in new york new york should be
given back to the canarsie the canarsie
uh
india you know we bought it for 60
gildersworth i'm sure they want it back
oh it was 60 guilders i believe it was
60 gilders i think it's
more valuable 10 000 pelts and all this
stuff the point is they sold it back
before they had ships
or bridges nice so you spruced it up
give it back all right that works
you know what's a little scalping uh
let's go to dominion there's a lot going
on with dominion and i said that
conservatives who are relying on the on
the voter fraud
uh built within the machines will be
disappointed that can't be the only
argument but it does seem
uh to be gaining ground and there is an
increasing
num there's an increasing amount of
deeply disturbing evidence
you already have enough with people who
are voting for out of state people who
are either underage or people who are
dead
voter roles that aren't act you already
have enough you already have enough just
with in georgia just that margin right
you have to throw those out
you have to throw those out thanks no
matter who they voted for by the way
right they were all 100 donald trump we
would still be saying you have to throw
those out there illegal votes yeah but
they never are they are so let's not
waste people
um so there is a victory i don't want
them to leave here confused
there was a giant vote dump that was for
trump no you mean nowhere in the nation
it ever
is no no not even in idaho
[Laughter]
he's real because there are no vote
dumps in idaho that's true it's like
five
just a lot of dumps so uh this is a
victory in michigan now they are going
to be able a judge
has uh uh given a i don't know this is
where we don't have a half a million
bills
that's a ruling if it's a grant uh i
don't know what kind of a warrant to
seize
uh dominion voting machines in michigan
well the big news
coming out of interim county michigan
this morning pete is that a judge
actually granted our team access to 22
of the dominion voting machines for us
to conduct a forensic audit
i'm going to get to something exclusive
here that i can tell you is confirmed
it's been circulating on the internet
about votes being switched but first i
want to present to you the publicly
available information that many of you
may not have already procured
uh here is actually um an expert with
witness uh russell ramsland
is it ramsland yeah ramsey
too bad this is live we could have cut
that
i've got that post oh boy there's no
post and now just because
you didn't appreciate it i know i'm
going to have to go back to it
you really will make sure that you have
to redeem it at some point
so russell ramsey uh presented some
findings that were showing that uh
dominion voting systems and this can get
a little bit
a little bit technical jargon but i'll
explain the context afterward i just
want you to know that
this was someone who spoke again under
penalty of perjury so you know it's not
just me saying it in my pajamas while
open carrying but that's because the
election hasn't been called yet yeah
so i have my buddy walter with yeah here
he is talking about dominion voting
systems overrepresenting biden
uh when compared to all other again a
comparison
voting systems here you go well the
first thing we wanted to do
was to see uh what the effect was
of a dominion machine compared to one
other and we looked at it or
compared to a group of others and we
looked at it from three points of view
and the first thing we did is we tried
to
go through the 20 uh
objections demographics
2020 vote count by county for the
country
and um then we also got the election
assistance committee voting machine
information so we knew what each county
had
you get a pretty good mathematical model
as to what you should expect to see
in a biden versus trump
by county vote we could see on a
percentage basis
whether um biden for instance
outperformed
you know by a certain percentage
giuliani underperformed
by a certain percentage what you would
expect in a county
well in this case what we noticed is
when we went back
and looked at it instead of all
voting equipment all over the country
and we simply segmented out dominion
we found out that biden outperformed
what
he should have by about five percent we
went back
and we looked at it instead of
percentage of out performance or
underperformance
we looked at it by counties and when we
did it by counties we found an even more
startling result we found out that if
dominion counts your votes
mr biden got about 78 percent
of the of the wins and if you
use all other voting machines then
um you you only got about a 46
now let me clarify something because you
might be saying oh wait hold on biden
got 78
versus that just depends on the county
you know what they're talking about is
comparing across counties across red
blue counties all other voting systems
in other words they have taken this into
account as a sample study
versus just dominion we're not talking
about going from new york city
right to idaho right we're not talking
about going from detroit
to let's say houston texas we're talking
about an average
across all other voting systems and my
god hats off to giuliani that man is a
hero he went from
prosecuting the mob you have any idea
how exciting that is
to listening to what is frankly the
audio it's paint drying
and this is a problem let me explain to
you this is the problem with the
conservative movement
okay there are too many kirk there are
too many sparks not enough kirks
yeah and i'll tell you this it's a show
that that we do very well and we try to
obviously check our sources you have a
lot of the think tank conservatives who
like for for example tucker carlson used
to be amongst them who think that this
is
beneath them and so they don't distill
information so that you can understand a
lot of people watch that and go i don't
know
uh what this exactly means and the media
is counting on you tuning out
like i did during
the show you'll notice an uptick in
energy i took a nice
45 second nap that's about all i needed
like two hours of sleep at night 45
second nap
with my eyes open your machine oh like a
dolphin let's apply this to the entire
state let me break it down for you
all other voting machines versus
dominion 78 versus 40 something percent
apply it to the state
that means that it could have given
biden anywhere from 123 236 000 votes
that's beyond the margin of victory
something else that pisses me off
i was listening to npr this morning and
they uh were talking about you know the
con
they are contesting the results donald
trump in georgia despite
no evidence of voter fraud after several
recounts
where the margin is 12 000 votes
it was 15 000 before the recount and
that's just a recount
of the machine mind you right i don't
know how it's
possible to find 5 500 votes i don't
know how that happens
so when npr says despite the recounts
why don't you give us a score card
of what the votes were after the
recounts this is just recounting the
ballot this is just recounting the
ballots in the machine
maybe we need a hand recount which
brings me to
something really important and this is
something that's been circulating online
and uh well i can't tell you exactly uh
where i've uh
procured some information i do believe
the source 95
okay uh this is confirmed and there will
be a sworn affidavit confirmed
hand recount in georgia this is
important so we're talking about the
machines in
georgia machine okay total then
recounted in the machine okay total a
hand recount
found uh out of nowhere uh when they
finally when they did a recount of the
votes
an increase of 37 votes for donald trump
this same hand reaccount found exactly
a subtraction of 37 votes from biden hmm
interesting machine same results
ah as a result this result hold that's
hand recount oh buying game 37
sorry trump game 37 did buy to lose any
37
37 bushes how does that this is
something and this is something
that's been circulating i think we
actually have uh
congressman jody heiss confirmed it and
here is an email
confirming the uh 37 vote switch and i
will tell you that i've spoken
uh with a source that i can't disclose
right now
you know that that's something important
because i don't always list anonymous
sources nope
i'm not like cnn and you'll find this
out soon enough in a court of law yeah
absolutely and not only that this person
was supposed to testify the person's
talking about the 37 votes not your
move not your deep throat right yeah
they they push them down to the
the can like the witness list like get
get down there at the bottom and then oh
we don't have enough time to get by the
way
you know why this witness has gone after
a republican's heart yeah just to be
clear
this witness who goes after both
republicans and democrats the
republicans were not happy with this
witness and they moved him down the list
of 37 votes
switched exactly so right now we've
seized the voting machines we found a
difference between dominion and all of
the votes we just saw
the fraud that had taken place in
georgia with a massive voter dump there
where is the evidence take it to court
well if a judge doesn't look at this
what do you do listen we're trying to
take it to court look we need a hand
recount 37
37 it's almost like it's an exact
equation
and this is one of the things too you
don't necessarily just rely on
statistics to go to court right but you
do rely on statistical anomalies to tell
you where to dig and to do research
and that is absolutely a place where you
go well hold on this
you can't outperform only on this
machine and only in these places and by
the way people watching right now again
comment did you know about this the 37
vote switch
telling you 95 i can confirm this
because
there are a lot of rumors circulating
that aren't necessarily accurate right
yes this is one that piqued my interest
i'm pretty sure it's accurate and if you
apply that across the state that's more
than enough to flip the state
that's a point three percent mark it's
it's more than enough right
not even including the other stuff yeah
it's like it's like uh they're saying
this it's like a paleontologist like dr
you know finding a bone and then going
hey i think there might be a dinosaur
here and they go
that dinosaur there's just a bone that's
right there's no need to dig anymore
no that's just a bone that's not even a
bone actually right there's no bone
there what are you talking about
oh yeah yeah there's no evidence of
dinosaurs
you guys just said bone three times and
joe lewis doesn't even nothing
what is the word that would look you see
that he just twitched don't worry he's
not dead he's thinking about killing a
squirrel
is there a word that would make him go
puppy dreams there really isn't no
let me see bring him up squirrel
bone hold on wait betty
no okay he's out out cold is
out all right that's the last time i
give my
dog ghb um and this is also important
when you say look at all these
irregularities and we don't have
how did all this happen how did these
votes get lost it's important to
remember
think the reason we don't have a free
and fair election getting outside of the
statistics
getting outside of the data that we have
getting outside of the video evidence
the macro here that really matters if
we're talking about a free society the
constitutional republic
is that throughout all of this election
people
specifically of one side have been
intimidated harassed and berated and we
have hundreds of affidavits again under
threat of perjury
uh showing this to be the case not to
mention anecdotal personal experience
this is where we are in this country
i was unable to challenge a ballot due
to the consistent intimidation
harassment and verbal attacks throughout
the day
this came from democrat challengers
independents a lawyer
team leaders supervisors i was
threatened to be escorted out by a
democrat lawyer
it was a hostile environment from the
democratic lawyer that told me i didn't
know what i was talking about when i was
challenging
writing down the seo number and then two
democrats stood up you know blocked my
view
and a supervisor came over grabbed my
credential and took 400 left
so that's how i was treated i personally
i witnessed
employees taking their pen very
differently filling in the democrats
an announcement that a new shipment of
ballots were
arriving and these boxes of belts were
brought in by mr baxter himself
at 4 30 a.m from the rear of the room
mr baxter and his uh management team got
back on the microphone
and said this is what democracy is is
supposed to look like
right in front of everyone the whole
room cheered yeah i was assumed to be a
democrat
this is that racist self-loathing some
women who
came to you and said let that let get
let's get these mf's out
and she was singing that song and she
was targeting white
male republicans accusing them of
something like
your mask slipped you were not six feet
away so you need to go out and you know
your phone was out and they were really
intimidating all these white people
and i put myself out there trying to
help them saying why are you
getting them in trouble and they said
why are you taking their side then
then i showed my gop tag and then she
said to me that i am on the wrong side
and then when i asked one lady uh where
did you get trained she said
train for what because they didn't know
what they were there for their
only job i could tell there was to block
the gop people from challenging
or intimidate them and get them out
that's the lady who they tried to
portray as racist because she
now she shouldn't have used the word
ciao but yeah that was a mistake
you know who's typically not offended
asians senator hirono not withstanding
well that uh but she said this is her
testimony they're just covering the fact
that she said
all chinese people look alike what she
said was listen how can you understand
and people will say this is doing i
guess indian voice now the equivalent to
black
face black voice i don't know i'm
offended whatever happened yeah well
we can all agree that this is grossly
offensive
and somehow we do and get it but she
said
you know how can you verify when you
have people who don't show up with a
signature with
many people think that all indian people
look alike and so and
i understand and i also find that all
chinese people look like in other words
she's saying that people who are not
indian aren't as familiar and this is
this is backed up by stages doesn't mean
that you hate people
it means that if you are not as familiar
with people you are more likely to
confuse them for a similar looking
person and she was saying i also feel
that way with chinese people
which listen describe one of those
people to a sketch artist a police
sketch artist and they're going to be
much more similar than your mom your dad
or your brother
you know who else thinks that a lot of
asian people look alike apples
face technology do you remember that
story years ago that it could it would
unlock on any asian face
we thought the technology would bring us
past hate no no
apparently we're still there so
fortunately we can watch that
like i would say rewind watch that
montage again and ask yourself is if
that's the kind of environment where
everything's
totally above like everything is totally
fine everybody's doing
trying to be as honest trying to make
sure that the results are as clear and
as easy as possible
so again saying like this is what
democracy looks like pulling out a bunch
of ballots let's get these mfr's out
it's it's a horrendous environment
assistant yeah and every single
republican there no matter what they
look like was treated like garbage
and the one man threw a stack of ballots
at the back of my head and it hit me he
said don't worry
plenty more where that came from wow
no return of dresses
one of the most telling things though is
how quickly the media was ready to carry
the water
right the media immediately before any
evidence had been presented we just said
hey there's some irregularities oh wait
hold on a second
okay hold on a second i want to because
we're going to go to this next sorry
yeah
california oh yeah christmas let's see
although as much as i just grew there
poppy harlow
that's not puppies that's not poppy
harlow
all
that's the virus just 44 days from now
let's get over to jessica dean she's
joining me now she's got all of this
just show me one person at cnn who's
disgusted yeah with
a mayor threatening to arrest people for
losing their house if they don't
they don't share your values america
let's see joe biden and come
here oh no they just left the california
you know why because it's not very good
for them
so she's reporting from delaware because
that's where joe biden was born
yeah is that what's going on i thought
it was scranton yeah no i was born in
delaware
but i was raised in amy's diner strength
in the local boxing club down by the
pool
really amy's diner's not a thing that's
what that's what you say
no it's not a thing can you verify it ah
kamal it's time for me to develop that
disease we've been talking about
i broke my leg step out of the way
you're crying out loud
i've never met anyone so full of [ __ ] in
my life as joe but
like donald trump's a bser yeah right
like but you know like unemployment is
great right unemployment is the best
ever people
the one thing i thought was really funny
in his speech the statistics folks
that don't make sense where i had people
come in from
we won the how we gained seats in the
house that wasn't supposed to happen
okay we gained state legislatures that
wasn't supposed to happen
and i had people come up to me they said
you're the one who led all this
and i thought i was going to lose and i
won and you're so much more
popular than me people love you so much
more than me
but you lost how is that he said you're
so much more beloved
than me he said you'll find a bullet and
i bet you there probably was a
conversation where the guy said you know
what i thought that i might be on death
door with my campaign and
i thought for sure you might win and i
might not but yeah i don't know how this
happened
so you're saying that people think
you're a pile of festering crap
and i am juice
nobody thought it was possible nobody
thought it was but actually
people said it couldn't happen i love it
versus versus joe biden saying i met
with the pope on thursday
right like uh no pope didn't meet with
you
you were you were in your barca lounger
with the dog while he was breaking your
ankle apparently
the pope says you didn't and he's
infallible yeah exactly oh
let's not get into it no no i didn't
comment
comment comment about
uh let's go to california the hypocrisy
here with kovid
which is remarkable i will tell you well
all right
um first let's go to this story and then
i will give it started with this
garcetti
mayor garcetti sounds like the guy in an
old cop film who nobody likes
i've got garcetti on my ass oh yeah he
hasn't been in the field in years but he
has me doing paperwork
it's time to bring in the cobra there's
any hate cobra guys said he hates
everything good
so garcetti issued a stay-at-home order
in california and i will say this uh
people will say this
i'm not an extremist at all uh but
the solution with cat with los angeles
is move when they have a stay-at-home
order
which means you can be arrested for
leaving your house
right including walking bicycling that's
the order now yep yeah
it's not just outdoor dining so we'll
get to the outdoor dining and the
hypocrisy there
but in the united states of america
where someone tells you because there's
only a
0.03 survival rate if you're on the age
of 60
that you have to stay home or face a
rest
uh you move in california but if that
actually were to happen on a national
level with joe biden
1776 have it for far less than that yeah
absolutely i'm telling
if it gets and please please joe biden
i'm i am
urging the left do not overreach at a
national level because i understand
federalism people can move from the crap
hole that is los angeles i would add i
would recommend that they do so and
thank god that we have some sheriffs who
said they refused to
enforce this order hey listen police
officers we backed you
you hold the line now for us you arrest
someone for leaving their house
you won't have our support yeah i want
to be clear about that you
are now the defenders of our freedoms
you're not just enforcing the law you
are enforcing the constitutional
liberties of all americans if you have a
governor if you have a mayor who is
saying
arrest that man because he left his
house to go purchase baby formula
whatever the hell it is
you need to say no yeah otherwise we
have a problem with you if that happens
on a national level
you will see and i do not want it to
come to this you will see
unrest like you have never seen in this
country and you know what
you've always got to give an injured
tiger and out don't back him into a
corner
if you tell americans that they have to
stay home or face arrest
i don't know what other options they
have at that point because right now
they're going through the courts
you don't want them to they're going
through the the courts of public opinion
you ban them from the courts of public
opinion in big tech
you have video evidence of election
fraud you have affidavits you have
statistical evidence you try and get
before a judge they just dismiss it
and then if you actually on a national
level say we're going to lock you in
your homes well the courts don't work
well the public opinion uh doesn't work
the town square is no longer available
to them what option do they have don't
do it
right yeah it's on the citizenry too
right now that we have to kind of flick
the jab just a little bit and say
okay we have to go out in march now
right black lives matter did it and they
said that was okay we're gonna go out
and actually do it peacefully unlike
what they did
let's everybody in these counties get
together and say hey fine
arrest all of us then because we're
going on a walk right we're gonna go on
a peaceful protest which is our
constitutional right to do
you know who i wish go for it would go
on a walk garcetti on a long walk off a
uh
short a short beer oh that's so lovely
those piers are always so short then he
would get wet he
didn't tell me there were rocks under
the waves
right off the shore is that a song does
anybody know this
name no no
because i'm doing it all for lena
dunham no on the same album there's a
song about phone sex which i listened to
as a kid and i had no idea and i went
back and
i was like mom dad you let me listen to
this billy joel glass houses all right
so garcetti shut down small restaurants
to give you specifics small restaurants
uh
outdoor dining completely uh but they
gave an exemption to essential by the
way essential workers in 2020
is for some reason films that no one can
watch anyway
here's a lady who fought back who was
furious
so this is my place the pineapple hill
grill in saloon if you go to my page you
can see all the work i did
for outdoor dining for tables being
seven feet apart
and i come in today because i'm
organizing a protest and
i came in to get stuff for that
and i walk into my parking lot and
obviously mayor garcetti has approved
[Music]
this
[Music]
has approved
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
[Music]
wow i'm losing everything everything i
own is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here
couple of things first off even with the
mask i can tell that you are quite the
dish
so find solace in that
i'm just saying lots of guys think
you're fine
so that's a good thing about losing your
livelihood more important
because beauty is only skin deep you're
just going deep so
jesus oh boy when people are talking
about the sacrifices like dwayne the
rock johnson
never touched steroids by the way once
in college and they terrified me
you
you're just larger veinier and leaner at
50 than you were at 35
and i can't even measure the growth of
your forehead
but when there's something people go out
and say hey hey hey we we
just listen let's all make the sack
let's all make a sacrifice
you first yeah okay how about that
especially
right now you should be out of work
anyway because nobody's going to see the
films you've shut down the local a lot
of people don't understand this they go
to a local movie theater and they see it
real
as a really big place yeah that ghost is
grandiose look at all these seats
this must be owned by a billionaire just
like if you go into no a lot of these
people they own franchises okay
that is a small business that's a
mom-and-pop business and a lot of these
scenarios
that's one of the beauties of the united
states equities and the ability to own
franchises i know a guy
who didn't finish college you know i
became a millionaire he opened up a
handful of jack in the boxes yeah
doesn't make a ton from each one but
when the the the chain was
uh was sort of just exploding much like
my ass after jack in the box
yeah but he didn't work double he
cleaned up he didn't work
doubles yeah and going back to your
earlier point about the police if you're
in lapd and you're afraid of losing your
job so if you if you say like
well i have to enforce this crazy
lockdown stuff because
if i don't i'll lose my job well mayor
garcetti wants you to lose your job
anyway
right he wants to defund
to keep your job and then he takes away
your job and then you go oh
i thought you said you'd kill me last i
lied that's what happened right
that's how this ends he doesn't want
anyone to have a job
and that's why i still say we yukon
cornelius just axe pick california push
it off into the middle of the ocean
silver
which is worth less than gold pick it
yukon i don't maybe he was understanding
maybe it was about investing
in silver because more appreciation yeah
i have no idea there's more silver
than gold [ __ ] catheters mortgages he
could have been watching a lot of people
that's my point
so garcetti we hear the term tone death
yeah thrown around but garcetti is
beyond
not even close he responded with this my
heart goes out to mrs marsden
and the workers at the pineapple hill
saloon who have to comply
with the state and the county that's you
public health restrictions that close
outdoor dining
oh okay maybe he's gonna no one likes
these restrictions
but i do support them as our hospital
icu beds fill the capacity and kate
whoa okay so my heart goes out to you
what are you gonna do
nothing hmm
what about for uh what about for pot
shops well listen people got to get
their weed
yeah we need them complacent and stupid
now i'm not serious
yeah i was just going to say that it was
illegal to have a pot shop in california
what 10 years ago and now it's essential
that's how it works take notes you silly
churches
[Laughter]
hot surfaces um wait a minute have we
have we seen them ask for the the ss
whatever cruise ship that came to new
york have they asked for that have they
asked for samaritan's purse to come and
set up field hospitals and stuff like
that to make sure that they can handle
this
virtue signal age they can't ask for
samaritan's purse then they'd be
importing christians
oh well that's true well is there like a
satanic temple that can set up a
hospital
for them because they're known for that
hey you know what i got a better idea
where are all the muslim charities yeah
where's the muslim samaritan's purse
going into 50 death rate ebola a little
bit more than
0.3 i would say right tomato
zero through 49.7 so the point here is
where this is one thing we never talk
about where are the islamic charities
going and helping people
yeah and if things really where are they
shutting down their mosques yeah
they're not at all and if things really
are that bad where you have to cut off
people's livelihoods for a month in the
busiest time of year for most of these
people
right then you need to be making plans
to bring those people in show us the
plans
let us know that it really is a serious
this year has been characterized by a
lot of people who don't understand
proportionality of danger right so it's
it's the covid right which again the
point for
three percent death rate of course and
then also
the uh like hunting of black men unarmed
black men by police officers
which again is very unlikely even for
unarmed black men to experience
so these are people who don't understand
what real danger is but
are afraid of a tiny tiny scale of um
tripling unemployment right yeah exactly
yeah real danger is closing down how
much is your life
worth uh that's not for you to say
because uh if i weren't a christian you
would just see an exit wound
uh in 2020 in the back of my chrome dome
it is but but that yeah 0.3 percent
versus
tripling unemployment how many poor
people start how many more people starve
how many more people kill themselves
because of depression how many people go
into substance abuse yeah this is the
yeah you need to wait and not to mention
let's erase all of it
you don't have the right yeah no it
doesn't matter if it's a church i have
the right to host a party
provided i'm not disturbing the peace
yeah and and the people who are
the are making these decisions are the
people who are furthest removed from
their consequences
right and and we do have clips that show
we do have clips and uh by the way this
is also governor news from his recent
state home order
um said you couldn't celebrate
thanksgiving but he exempted
entertainment workers
was that the source oh that's what was
that that really hurt whatever was that
token
no no guess we did we not have this
that's what this whoa while you're
supposed to be working dude
that's not the overlapping i had like
three overlays oh okay
focus well that wasn't amongst any of
them you could have 30 overlays there's
no reason
no one of the three are you at least did
you you have expressvpn on that computer
though right so people can't
track that horribly embarrassing search
of yours okay i mean other than just
broadcasting
but for people out there who aren't
stupid enough to broadcast
on air your fat pride uh erotica not
quite pornography not quite
he's not stupid go to expressvpn.com you
get three months
free uh expressvpn that's what we use
when we did the algorithm searches with
topsy uh
gabbard and some of our various changes
so it's different it's not just for
gibbons it's not just for gibbons fat
erotica
uh we use it we all use it here
expressvpn it's the only major vpn that
you hear uh run as a sponsorship on some
of these shows
that didn't actually have a major data
security which
one could almost argue defeats the
purpose yeah
so stop handing uh your data over listen
to big tech companies this is i don't
ever need you
listen i don't need to read copy with
any of my my sponsors because i actually
use it
yeah yeah okay i use expressvpn yeah the
only issue is one time it kicked me off
on it didn't play well with apple and
then they did an update
and that's good that's the past but i
just don't why would you willingly give
it
give your dad a big deck expressvpn.com
you get three months free they support
the show
and uh it's a good vpn okay here's
another one
uh los angeles county the supervisor
sheila cool is that how it's pronounced
i don't know
sure voted to again ban all outdoor
dining which she described as the most
dangerous situation that's what she
described
a most dangerous situation because
apparently she lives in
dickens era that sounds like a movie
title dining out
on the buffalo wildlings patio i believe
to be the most
dangerous situation positively sticky
i say
soon you shall find yourself permanently
resting in your pine overcoat
don't represent us oh don't say that was
close
i said a bad word it's a pejorative ah
it wasn't a compliment
[Laughter]
she described it as a most dangerous
situation and a few hours later
she did this last tuesday just hours
after supervisor keel called outdoor
dining
dangerous then voted to ban it she
visited a local restaurant and
dined outdoors no basically
one set of rules for them and listen to
the guy with a hockey cut
testified what a dangerous situation the
outdoor dining
is and the keeper turns right around and
dines so i mean i don't think these
people even really believe
what they're saying that's the important
point here these do you really believe
when you look at some of these hearings
even in georgia do you really believe
that people are actually terrified of
this now do i believe that
people out there live in greater fear
typically liberals have more mental
health
illness disorders that's absolutely and
i say this is someone who struggles with
mental health
and i'm a conservative i'm an anomaly
okay can't put me in a box i don't like
labels
they have more mental health issues they
tend to be more motivated by fear that
is a fact as opposed to and if
the things that they fear are insecurity
versus
a lack of freedom a lack of liberty so
uh
i do believe that they are more afraid
of a virus because they don't know that
it's a you know 99.999 whatever percent
survival rate yeah but do you really
believe that they are terrified when you
see them go outside and they go and they
dine at a restaurant when they don't
think anyone's watching when nancy
pelosi
if nancy pelosi actually believes what
she's telling
you to believe she would never ever go
to get a blowout
by the way where it's a particle aerosol
vortex okay
these people would never go and eat
outside at circular table whatever the
hell it is i'm not really up to
speed on my franchises i eat at home
this is
this is one of those do you really
believe in your heart of hearts
that they are afraid of it because i
will tell you this if ebola was out
there like when samaritan's purse was
one of two organizations the one with a
50
survival rate i'd be howard hughes
pissing in jars i wouldn't go out no
not at all you wouldn't find me at
cowboy chicken well
i think with miss kewl here the the
danger really started at 5 p.m the next
day
that was uh that was why she was like oh
it's totally fine i mean tomorrow
hell comes and well she yeah she she did
eat outside but she had a sad face the
whole time
yeah that was good yeah frowny face yeah
what was that show me again
okay hey we've got a couple hey that was
like
that's your sad face or your sex face no
jeez i'm not going to make it by the way
by the way hold on
but if ever you like really want to make
your wife laugh don't
don't do a bit don't do a sex face bit
it ruins it for a while it does it was a
long drive
she's like that's not funny this is not
the time
because i think
[Music]
she's like don't do yourself too close
i said like wouldn't it be this or my
sex face she was like this is we're done
yeah but you put on you put on the
corner
yeah all right what are we gonna say
they're talking about we didn't play
wealthy
yeah so we we just heard that the sydney
powell hearing uh just adjourned
and we haven't here we have a couple of
updates we do have a couple of updates
there we go judge timothy baden has just
rejected from the bench sidney powell's
lawsuit seeking to block certification
of georgia election results
lovely he becomes latest in a string of
gop appointed judges by george w bush to
toss suit alleging election fraud
and then at the same time pretty much we
got obama judge dismisses
sidney powell requests for preliminary
injunction in michigan
wow oh well you know what
who cares if 37 votes were switched in
videographic again
now to be clear this isn't even a trump
suit so when the media says trump is
sydney powell doesn't work for the trump
team right there are plenty of other
people who filed suits including
independent people who trump's lawyers
work alongside
now uh that just shows you that no
evidence is enough
none whatsoever what would you really
have to have at this point do you think
for
anybody to take notice and i i mean like
we've said the media the judges the
people who are supposed to be the
gatekeepers
in the states the governor the secretary
of state all these people what would you
need to see there's no accountability
because if these look if these judges
get it wrong there's no accountability
yeah good example
isn't there a fine or something in cal
not only being arrested but potentially
a fine for
disobeying the state home orders has
newsome paid any of his fines
garcetti yeah what about cool have any
of them had any arrests percussions at
all
no you do they don't same thing with
judges
you suffer the consequences they don't
yeah
apparently it also just it wasn't just a
matter of like not enough
evidence it was uh that judged timothy
baden he had said that
um the dominion voting system had been
around since like before the election
and so we could have had it before yeah
well they did
people we could have had the dominion
voting before the complaint before
the complaint yeah well it was rejected
in texas there were plenty of people who
raised awareness including
elizabeth warren democrats did it yeah
they didn't really care
republicans do it they don't really care
states reject it
no there's a long track record of
problems with dominion from both the
right and the left
just right like right now there is a
track record of corruption from judges
both the right and the left and i use
the term right loosely at geo
judge appointed by george w bush come on
and george biden yeah the judges
did uh actually watch the young turk
coverage of it
right well no if you think about it this
way if you're going to be excoriated in
the media
punch yeah if you're going to be
excoriated in the media if this judge
had said yes let's let this go
to trial oh i can't believe these
radical right-wing judges
he does this and it's oh this judge is
just wonderful they don't judge it by
the merits at all no would they just
judge it by whether they
say americans out there you need to
react
you need to peacefully assemble you need
to protest
you need to write your officials because
this is probably going to be punted up
to the supreme court
and they need to feel like they can
stick their neck out for you
that's why you don't act like a
defeatist little weasel now
yeah it's not the time to this isn't
over
this is far from over this is what
people think
you can always see this happen the
closer you get to potentially losing
more people drop out because they
ultimately want to be on the winning
side to be able to say i told you so
look i'm not looking for and i told you
so
i will continue fighting until and if
there
is a loss because it matters to fight
sometimes you fight for the sake of
[ __ ] fighting it's not because you
have to win
right you don't you can win yeah but you
don't know that you will
right and the supreme court needs to see
that from you you got
conservatives who just sort of i guess
slink out at this point
listen you are making the loss more
likely
not less likely you will become a
self-fulfilling prophecy this
is upsetting but it's not unexpected
right no we definitely expect it and the
time to get angry and to do something
about it is not
january 20th it's too late then right
you have to stand up and say hey this is
what we feel right now you have to go
and look into this otherwise we don't
have free fair elections and so
so many of these judges have heard the
media narrative but they may have never
heard the opposite narrative i may have
actually never heard anything be
contradicted like well here here are the
facts on this and here and
because again you can present a handful
of facts but if you don't have a
contradictory
a narrative that contradicts the media's
narrative then you don't have anything
you can't actually put
the facts down okay if you were to sit
down this judge right now or many of
these judges in georgia and say
hey by the way this is their excuse
right now but what about the fact that
the night of
they said a pipe burst and they said
that they had sent people home and
counting stopped
are you aware of that say well there
might have been one miscommunication
then show them our montage here's cnn
abcbs fox news and cnn and pbs again bbc
maybe the judge might go oh that's
relevant because
the video matches what they initially
told us at the very least
we know at some point along the trail
there's a severe miscommunication which
is a problem or someone is lying
more likely which is a problem i don't
know that the judges know this
and i and this has happened before you
can see these in
very well publicized cases this is this
idea we somehow think that people from
the bench
are beyond error they're not do you
think that these all of a sudden because
they put a judge's robe on that they
understand
algorithmic data they don't that's why
there's such thing as an expert witness
and at this point they're not allowing
the expert witness to come forward
and explain it right and just to
highlight your point when john roberts
basically rewrote law which was not the
purview of the supreme court with
obamacare
that's a great example of a justice
doing something that a justice should
never do
right it happens and if it can happen in
the supreme court it can certainly
happen in
other courts throughout the economy of
course uh all right listen we do have to
get going pretty soon but uh we have a
few more examples of the covet stuff
uh city lock down blah blah blah blah
blah blah you know let's go to
california mayor rex paris let's go to
that one
this one is pretty funny he declared
that not wearing a mask in public was
quote an act of domestic terrorism wow
this one's from daily news i think
that's body odor
if it were up to me anybody not wearing
a mask when they are out in public would
be arrested
and boiled with his thanksgiving the
stake of holly cruz
i think you added the last part will be
arrested that's an act of domestic
terrorism and should be treated like
one keep in mind this is a state that
has been knowingly exposing people to
aids right they removed the consent law
right hold on a second before you
pound me in the rear i would like to
know
do you have a disease that could lead to
my
loss of life and or severe decline of
quality of life again before you uh
found my uh my rear could you i am not
legally required to disclose that well
good enough for me
this is
in california removed consent laws for
aids used to be
if you have aids or sorry disclosure
laws you have to say hey by the way
before i absolutely plow you i've got
aids what was that
too late it's just like this is and
they're saying
an act of domestic well listen let me
ask you this is it an act of domestic
terrorism
for someone at the folsom street fair to
knowingly infect someone else with aids
and not wear a rubber
you've ruled no but not wearing a mask
which by the way anyone out there
i want you guys to comment show me the
data that shows the masks that people
are using the reusable
home cotton cloth polyester masks when
they are not washed
in a commercial hospital system washing
machine
that it actually works i'm not talking
about n95 masks
i'm talking about you and your your
glorified pashmita okay
i want to know what data exists to show
that
that verifiably works because i have not
seen it and i of course accept that
surgical masks work in their appropriate
clinical settings
provided they are disposed of there yes
thank you very much yeah so
all of a sudden they're comfortable
throwing the word terrorism around right
yeah the left loves using the word
terrorism just to describe people going
to the store without their without
cloth on their face did you almost it's
us no i i think i was just stumbling
over myself
i thought i heard an f and i was like
yeah wade yeah no what about the guy the
guy who went down to the piggly wiggly
uh to pick up some diapers and didn't
wear a mask
terrorist what about the guy who yelled
out allahu akbar and ran over people
with a postal truck
i'm not sure let's not jump to
conclusions
the fact that you represent anybody yeah
means the founding fathers missed some
fine print
uh that other person is an austere
religious scholar yeah i think his part
was free
that's right yeah no that's exactly
correct we have to be careful
well i don't know listen that man didn't
wear a mask that's terrorism keep in
mind
terrorism and we're going to go after
this by the way comment everybody
watching now
if you are watching the archive because
you can't comment while it's streaming
live just leave a comment
your thoughts will do and ask me
anything down the line ask any questions
you want
list your favorite color how are you
going to fight back just comment
whatever it takes you five seconds
um well terrorism people need to
understand terrorism isn't just violence
terrorism
is violence committed within the
ultimate ends
right the the goal is a political or
ideological motivation
so when you say someone not wearing a
mask is domestic terrorism well what is
the ultimate
this is a means to an ultimate
ideological end
which is what in this case i guess
someone wanting the freedom to
not be arrested yeah okay
we're talking about islam right they go
well the motivations we don't know if
it's terrorism again we understand that
terrorism is
a means to an ideological religious
theological philosophical end
we don't know the motivation that he was
yelling allahu akbar
jury's still out yeah we're not sure
yeah yeah
and it's like that's the only kind of
terrorism i've ever heard of you can do
accidentally
right like oh oops i was committing
terrorism because i forgot my mask in my
car
uh yes oh so sorry about that yeah
you're going you're getting like uh hold
on let me i gotta
i gotta go into kroger let me i have a
mask in the glovebox son of a [ __ ] i
have to commit some terror
it's like not wearing a mask not wearing
a mask is terrorism but
running down smashing the piggly wiggly
side yeah stealing all the piggly wiggly
stuff i have to kind of
tear it might as well make it count
right into the tom thumb so they will
remember my name
all right we have about 40 minutes more
show we are going to be playing
try to laugh a challenge over there on
snow for people who aren't subscribed to
mug club lighter with crowder.com club
again you comment that helps us
45 minutes more of show taking your chat
youtube
we've had enough of you piss off